It feels like it was certainly days ago, if
not a week ago, that I was warning you that
these paramilitaries in Portland, Oregon,
were just step one in a sort of trial balloon
for Donald Trump to deploy federal troops
to more cities against the desires of state
and local authorities against the desires
of mayors.
But that was yesterday.
It was just 16, 17 hours ago since our clip
published about these paramilitaries in Portland
being just step like zero point five.
And Donald Trump yesterday announced a plan
to deploy more troops to the city of Chicago.
Now directly counter to the desires of the
mayor.
Lori Lightfoot.
So let's take a look first at what Donald
Trump said yesterday, announcing this Free
America, no matter their income, their race
or their zip code, should be able to walk
their city streets free from violence and
free from fear.
For this reason, today, I am announcing that
the Department of Justice will immediately
surge federal law enforcement to the city
of Chicago.
The FBI, ATF, DEA, U.S. Marshal Service and
Homeland Security will together be sending
hundreds of skilled law enforcement officers
to Chicago to help drive down violent crime.
And murderers and violent criminals are breaking
a wide range of federal laws.
We have that.
It's as wide as it can be.
We will find them, arrest them and prosecute
them.
They will be in jail for many years to come.
Now, there are about four or five different
issues here.
So first, let's deal with the propaganda optics.
This idea of crime in liberal Democrat cities,
as Trump likes to say, is being used to justify
Donald Trump's reelection.
Now, you might wonder, well, hold on.
That doesn't doesn't seem obvious.
A crime in liberal Democrats.
It's Trump reelection paramilitaries in the
middle.
What's the path?
The path is weak.
Democrats who run liberal Democrat cities
aren't about law and order.
And you're going to get more of this if Joe
Biden were to win.
Now, on the other hand, you've got Donald
Trump.
Donald Trump is the law and order guy.
He won't hesitate to send in the troops, not
metaphorically, but literally to enforce the
law, as they say.
Now, there is a lot missing from this narrative.
First of all, remember that there is an urban
rural divide in the United States.
So when we hear the right say, look at all
these cities with high crime that are all
run by Democrats.
Well, remember, crime tends to be where you
have people in greater population density.
So by definition, the crime is mostly going
to be in cities and cities are more liberal
than rural areas.
So you are disproportionately going to have
Democrats running cities, both cities that
have higher crime and lower crime.
So it's essentially a nonfactor, but it's
being used at number one to start the propaganda.
Now, what's also missing from this narrative
is that right now we have a huge amount of
economic desperation.
We have every week we have two to 10 times
the new unemployment claims that previously
were the record.
Remember, the record previously was like six
hundred and fifty six hundred and seventy
five thousand jobless claims in a week.
We've had anywhere from one point three million
to six and a half million claims per week
for the last 16, 17 weeks of this pandemic.
So we have the economic destruction of coronavirus,
which, yes, partially relates to Donald Trump's
failed response, which is also a factor in
the desperation we are seeing that is leading
to some crime.
And then, you know, at least in Portland,
part of the escalation in tensions and violence
is because of these UN badged paramilitaries
showing up against the desires of local authorities
and throwing people into unmarked vans.
And that's also part of the play here.
So the idea is send in troops to cause and
foment confrontations in order to then justify
saying, well, we've got to send them to Chicago
as well, because look at what happened in
Portland.
Well, part of what happened in Portland is
because you sent in the troops.
Now, I already went over the legal part yesterday,
but it bears some repeating in case people
see this clip and not that clip.
The statute that the Trump administration
is citing as what gives them the right to
do this very clearly says that this author,
I believe it's 40 U.S. code.
Thirteen, fifteen.
But I may be misremembering.
It says the authority to send in federal law
enforcement is limit unilaterally is limited
to protecting buildings that are either owned
by the federal government or a building that
the federal government is using for an office.
So there might be a local landlord that owns
a building, but there's some federal government
office that is in there.
That is the limit of what the.
Federal government can go in and do now if
they want to go beyond federal property.
They may seek to get agreement with state
and local authorities.
They can work concurrently with state and
local authorities.
If state and local authorities want, that's
not what's happening in Portland, Portland
and now Chicago.
The mayors do not want them there.
They are not working with local law enforcement.
So their legal justification is absolutely
and completely bogus.
Now, let's step back for a second.
If this was happening in a different country,
there are many prior administration, both
Republicans and Democrats, that would say
we can't allow that to happen in another country.
Here is Donald Trump.
And I'm not saying we would sending our troops
to stop it in another country, but we would
speak out and say, that's not OK.
Here is Donald Trump doing this himself domestically,
OK.
So understand the contrast here.
Every conservative, as much as every liberal
should be disgusted by this.
And as I've said before, we're really six
weeks from the election in the sense that
the first early ballots and absentee ballots
can start coming in in a few states in six
weeks.
So this is a strategy from a desperate president
to create chaos and use the chaos he creates
to justify keeping the armed troops, sending
in more armed troops in major cities up through
to and including the election, in order to
intimidate voters, to incite Trump supporters,
to lay the groundwork to then question the
results of the election.
Now, there's a lot there.
Not every aspect of that will necessarily
happen.
But that's the big picture of why this is
happening.
This is exactly what I said yesterday and
Monday and late last week was going to happen.
And we're now going from just Portland to
Portland and Chicago and there's discussions
of more cities as well.
So this is not a test.
Guys, this is no joke.
This this is it.
This is no longer the rehearsal.
It's happening right now.
And I said in a segment on Tuesday that a
desperate Trump is a dangerous Trump.
We're seeing that front and center right now.
And this is about so much more than just this
election.
This is about so much more than a sort of
a cute Republican hypocrisy.
This is about morality.
This is about the Constitution, which the
right claims to hold almost as a sacred text.
This is about states rights being violated.
In fact, this is about a whole bunch of things
that the right claims to care about.
And by the way, you know, I, I if I ignored
this last bit of a dog whistle, I would not
be be thorough.
Chicago is part of the dog whistle.
Right, because Republicans for years have
been sort of using this dog whistle imagery
of dangerous, violent black urban youth in
Chicago, sending the troops there.
Next is part of the dog whistle to continue
inciting those exact same images.
And that is exactly what we are seeing here.
It is dog whistle politics.
It is a man acting out of desperation.
And I would be wrong if I said it definitely
won't work.
There is a chance.
And that's why this is so important.
There's a chance that not only will this be
morally wrong and legally wrong, there's a
chance that this actually will help Donald
Trump tweeting.
This is what, you know, images from Portland
saying this is what Joe Biden's America would
look like now.
What's crazy is it's actually Trump's America.
But this is the type of imagery that actually
can work.
It's very ugly.
Listen, we saw I mean, when it looked like
Benjamin Netanyahu in Israel was maybe going
to go down, this was years ago now, not in
the most recent election.
It was this type of this exact same type of
imagery and fear mongering that ultimately
got him reelected.
OK, so so writing this off is it definitely
won't work is not right.
We would be wrong to do that.
Let me know what your thoughts are.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
We have a lot of things to go over with you
today.
So we're keeping this first part of the show
a little shorter.
I accidentally clap there I was with.
And we will be right back momentarily
with
so much more that
we have to discuss.